bonjour à tous alors aujourd'hui on va
parler d'un auteur aussi connu que
méconnu aussi connu que le connu parce
que son nom le connaît à tel point qu'il
y avait un adjectif qui a été constituée
à partir de son nom
mais méconnu parce que en réalité cet
adjectif caractérise extrêmement mal la
doctrine philosophique de cet auteur cet
auteur c'est nicolas machiavel
philosophe florentin de la renaissance
et il est notamment connu pour avoir
publié un ouvrage intitulé le prince en
1513 qu'on pourrait définir comme une
sorte manuel à l'usagé des gouvernants
la philosophie de machiavel c'est une
philosophie essentiellement politique
alors je dis essentiellement parce que
on va voir qu'en réalité
sa philosophie n'est pas que politique
mais elle a une destination elle a une
vocation politique qui consiste à
définir l'art de gouverner
l'art de gouverner c'est vraiment ce qui
définit le mieux la chose politique
depuis l'antiquité
c'est à dire l'art de gérer l'art
d'administrer la vie dans la cité la vie
dans la communauté et l'art de gouverner
selon moi qui avais l'on va voir qu'il
sort un petit peu de l'ordinaire ou en
tout cas des normes politiques qui
étaient en vigueur jusqu'à son époque
alors je disais en introduction que cet
auteur était méconnu du fait qu'on
l'associé injustement un adjectif
machiavélique qui n'est pas
représentatif de sa doctrine
machiavélique sassi qui fait preuve
d'une intelligence malicieuse d'une
intelligence presque diabolique
il ya l'idée d'une malveillance ya
l'idée d'une mauvaise intention à la
base du machiavélisme alors que en
réalité chez machiavel il n'y a pas
cette idée de perfidie n'y a pas cette
idée de faire le mal pour faire le mal
mais en revanche il y à cette idée que
parfois dans certains cas de figure le
mal peut être à l'instrument pour
gouverner le peuple le mal peut être
utilisé pour conserver le pouvoir
on va voir que c'est ça le but ultime de
machiavel s'est édifié une science
technique est un art dont le but va être
la conservation de pouvoir
alors évidemment je précise toute
ressemblance entre ce qui va être
décrits dans cette vidéo est la réalité
de la politique contemporaine
bien entendu ne saurait être que
fortuite 1 il est évident que la
philosophie de machiavel n'a eu aucune
influence sur les gouvernants depuis le
15e siècle
et si j'utilise l'aironi c'est justement
parce que de nombreuses personnalités
politiques ont reconnu que machiavel
était une référence dans la politique et
que pour certains le prince était même
leur livre de chevet donc heureusement
déjà que l' influence de machiavel sur
la conception de la chose politique dans
la modernité a été absolument
déterminante et elle était d'autant plus
déterminante qu'elle s'opposait
strictement aux anciennes philosophie
politique c'est à dire principalement
aux philosophies politiques de
l'antiquité et du moyen âge
machiavel c'est vraiment le fondateur de
la philosophie politique moderne et si
on devait déjà identifié une première
idée maîtresse de la philosophie
politique moderne
on pourrait dire que c'est le réalisme
et qu'est ce que j'appelle réalisme
alors ici je ne parle pas de réalisme au
sens métaphysique un lien une doctrine
qu'on appelle le réalisme qui consiste à
dire que le monde est une réalité et ça
s'oppose à l'idéalisme qui consiste à
dire que le monde
une construction de l'esprit donc là je
parlerai pas de ce réalisme là je parle
du réalisme au sens us bell en fait
c'est à dire la prise en compte de la
réalité
l'acceptation de la réalité telle
qu'elle est et toute la philosophie de
machiavel est basée sur ce postulat ce
postulat réaliste qui consiste à dire
qu'on doit pas considérer les citoyens
comme on voudrait qu'il soit on doit les
considérer comme ce qu'ils sont on doit
partir de ce qu'ils sont et on ne doit
pas vouloir l'échangé on doit pas
vouloir les transformer en quelque chose
qu'ils ne sont pas et ce réalisme il
repose sur une certaine conception de
l'homme et cette vision l'homme elle
consiste à dire que nous sommes
incapables de bien cette idée de pascal
l'homme est incapable de bien et devrait
nous sommes incapables de faire le bien
parce que nous ne sommes pas mu par
l'amour de l'autre nous sommes mus par
l'amour de nous mêmes nous sommes mus
par l'intérêt par l'égoïsme
donc on aura beau nous ériger des
modèles de vertu des modèles de conduite
en aura beau promouvoir la morale et la
religion
en réalité ça ne sert à rien ça ne sert
à rien parce que l'homme est incapable
de s'élever vers le bien et ça ne sert à
rien d'attendre de l'homme quelque chose
dont il n'est pas capable
c'est ça le réalisme de machiavel c'est
la prise en compte factuelle de la
condition humaine et du comportement
humain c'est ce qu'on pourrait appeler
une anthropologie c'est à dire une
conception de la nature humaine qui
consiste à accepter
l'égoïsme fondamentale de l'être humain
et de s'appuyer là dessus pour gouverner
le peuple voilà l'idée s'appuyer sur les
vices de l'homme pour le gouverner vous
voyez que le réalisme de machiavel
s'accompagne inévitablement d'un
pragmatisme le pragmatisme c'est l'idée
que c'est le résultat qui compte
c'est l'effet produit qui compte ce ne
sont pas les principes qui ne sont pas
les valeurs idéales qu'on place en amont
de nos actions c'est le résultat dans la
pratique
or si l'objectif de la politique c'est
de gouverner si c'est bien l'art du
gouvernement de la cité
eh bien il faut commencer par partir de
la réalité la réalité c'est l'incapacité
de l'homme aux biens la réalité c'est
l'égoïsme structurel de l'homme
c'est son penchant au vice son penchant
aux passions et puisque l'homme est
ainsi fait il faut l'exploiter il faut
s'appuyer dessus pour pouvoir le
gouverner le but c'est de conserver le
pouvoir donc on fera tout pour conserver
le pouvoir et on n'acceptera de regarder
la réalité en face parce que ça nous
donnera les moyens de contrôler le
peuple
alors pour bien vous montrer en quoi
cette conception est totalement
révolutionnaire pour l'époque xvème et
xvième siècle je vais prendre deux
exemples
un premier exemple issus de l'antiquité
et un deuxième exemple du moyen-âge le
premier exemple c'est la république de
platon platon un auteur du 5e siècle
avant jésus-christ a écrit un ouvrage de
philosophie politique qui s'appelle la
république et dans lequel il expose ce
que seraient les fondements d'une
société idéale
alors je sais pour les puristes que
platon n'emploie pas l'expression de
cité idéale il emploie l'expression de
cali police c'est-à-dire la belle cité
la belle cité c'est la cité vertueuse
c'est la cité harmonieuse
c'est à la fois la cité qui est
fonctionnel mais qui est aussi en accord
avec le bien en accord avec l'idée du
bien les principes du bien donc c'est
pour ça que si vous divisez la
république de platon vous allez trouver
tout un tas de développement sur la
vertu ni sur la morale sur la nature du
bien parce que pour platon à l'époque il
n'est même pas envisageable de séparer
la politique de la morale on peut pas
séparer la politique de la vertu puisque
précisément la fonction de la république
la fonction du régime politique qui
administre la vie dans la cité
son principe même c'est de guider le
peuple vers le bien donc voyez ici que
la cité de platon elle est orientée vers
le bien les orienter vers la poursuite
du bien et on pourrait même aller plus
loin en disant que la cité à la vocation
à faire advenir l'idée du bien sur terre
la république à la vocation à
matérialiser le bien matérialiser le
bien de telle sorte que le bien idéal le
bien abstrait soit représentée sur terre
par l'intermédiaire de la société
retenez bien ça le projet politique de
platon il est inséparable de l'idée que
la politique est faite pour d'idées vers
le bien
maintenant je prendre un deuxième
exemple c'est l'exemple de
saint-augustin alors saint-augustin
cette fois ci on est au cinquième siècle
après jésus-christ saint-augustin a
écrit un ouvrage qui s'appelle la cité
de dieu dans lequel il décrit deux types
de sociétés totalement opposé le premier
type de société c'est la société qui
serait guidée par l'amour de soi
c'est-à-dire par l'égoïsme donc dans
l'esprit de saint-augustin par le vice
est une société qui serait fondée sur
l'amour de dieu et ça évidemment pour
saint-augustin c'est l'idéal politique
quel est le but selon saint-augustin de
la société et bien c'est tout simplement
de sauver les âmes c'est de sauver les
âmes parce que si le but de la société
c'est de créer le milieu mieux
l'environnement qui va faire que les
hommes vont s'élever à dieu dans ce cas
là la finalité c'est que tous les êtres
humains est au paradis
ça paraît idiot mais c'est vraiment ça
l'idée puisque dans une société
religieuse les principes qui gouvernent
ce sont les principes divins et les
principes divins qu'est ce qu'ils me
disent ils disent que la vie sur terre
n'est qu'un passage ils nous disent que
ce qui a vraiment de la valeur ce qu'a
vraiment du sens c'est la vie éternelle
c'est ce qu'il y aura après la vie
terrestre et comment est-ce qu'on accède
à cette ville éternelle en se comportant
dans notre vie terrestre en suivant les
principes de dieu c'est à dire en
souvent le principe du bien
donc ici encore on est dans une
conception de la politique qui n'est pas
dissociable de l'idée du bien qui n'est
pas dissociable d'un idéal morales
philosophiques et religieux qui va
constituer pour ainsi dire la clé de
voûte du système politique
donc là je pense que vous voyez
clairement où se situe la rupture dans
la conception politique de machiavel
c'est ce qu'on pourrait appeler une
rupture épistémologique c'est-à-dire un
renversement dans la conception du
gourou renversement de paradigme
un renversement paradigme ça veut dire
qu'on se situe littéralement dans un
autre monde
dans un monde où l'idée du bien n'est
plus quelque chose d'incontournable dans
lequel l'idée du bien n'est qu'une
option parmi d'autres mais dans lequel
en tout cas il ne faut surtout pas faire
de cette idée du bien le socle de la
décision politique
le socle de l'art de gouverner surtout
pas surtout pas parce que c'est une
entreprise vaines
c'est une entreprise qui n'est pas
conforme à la nature humaine et donc
c'est une entreprise qui est vouée à
l'échec c'est une entreprise qui est
voué à l'autodestruction
donc si le but de la politique c'est
d'obtenir et de conserver le pouvoir
on ne peut certainement pas baser
l'action politique sur des bases aussi
fragile que la tendance des hommes à
aller vers le bien que la tendance des
hommes à être vertueux que la tendance
des hommes à suivre les commandements
divins
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible
parce que ça ne marchera pas ça ne
fonctionnera pas donc inutile d'essayer
inutile de s'accrocher à une illusion
c'est ça le réalisme politique de mac la
donne alors ici j'aimerais faire une
petite parenthèse sur le contexte et
notamment sur le contexte historique
c'est à dire on est avec machiavel à la
renaissance
on est plus largement dans ce qu'on
appelle au modernité et la modernité
c'est vraiment le moment où on va
totalement changer de point de vue sur
l'homme
transformer la conception qu'on a de la
nature humaine et se diriger vers ce que
certains ont appelé un pessimisme
anthropologique
le pessimisme anthropologique ça rejoint
ce que je disais tout à l'heure sur la
vision la nature humaine camac label
c'est l'idée qu'on ne peut rien attendre
de l'homme
c'est l'idée que l'homme est d'abord
gouverné par la recherche de son intérêt
égoïste il est gouverné par ses pulsions
et ses sentiments et ça ne sert à rien
de faire semblant ça ne sert à rien de
se voiler la face et de vouloir que
l'homme soit autre chose que ce qu'il
est on va pas se leurrer on ne va pas
s'illusionner sur la nature humaine on
constate on accepte que l'homme est
égoïste on accepte la réalité de ce
qu'il est et on l'utilisera notre
avantage c'est vraiment ça l'idée est
retenue c'est vraiment ce qu'on pourrait
appeler ici un opportunisme politique
opportunisme qui va consistait à tirer
profit davis alors même que lévis était
autrefois considérée comme un obstacle à
la politique
donc on est vraiment comme au judo c'est
à dire qu'on va récupérer recycler la
force de l'autre à notre profit et pour
terminer là dessus donc parmi les
auteurs sont repris à leur compte
ce pessimisme anthropologique ou ce
réalisme anthropologique
ça dépend du point de vue on pourra
citer thomas hobbes philosophe anglais
du xviie siècle qui justement utilise la
même méthodologie dans son ouvrage
léviathan c'est à dire qu'ils commencent
par se livrer à une petite analyse de la
nature humaine pour finalement se rendre
compte que la seule chose qui peut faire
que l'homme va se comporter correctement
c'est la peur de la mort c'est l'idée
que nous sommes tous d'intarissables
égoïste que nous sommes tous en train de
nous entretuer en permanence pour
prendre au voisin ce qu'il a et que nous
n'avons pas parce que nous sommes jaloux
parce que nous sommes possessif parce
que nous voulons renvoyer nage
avantageuse de nous et c'est seulement
parce que l'homme à force de s'entretuer
a développé une angoisse de la mort
qu'il a décidé de remettre son pouvoir à
l'état pour qui le protège c'est ça
vraiment le le fondement anthropologique
de la doctrine de pops
c'est l'idée qu'il faut tenir compte de
la nature humaine prendre en compte l'
égoïsme de l'homme et s'appuyer sur cet
égoïsme s'appuyer sur cette nature
humaine pour le gouvernent et donc on
maquille label c'est exactement la même
chose il ne s'agit pas de dire au peuple
ce qu'il doit être
il s'agit de comprendre ce que le peuple
est pour pouvoir le gouvernement
et de la même façon le peuple on va pas
s'intéresser à style doit vouloir ou à
ce qui devrait vouloir on va
s'intéresser à ce qu'il veut réellement
parce que pour gouverner un peuple il
faut savoir ce que veut le peuple il
faut lui donner ce qu'il veut il faut
lui donner ce qu'il veut ou en tout cas
il faut lui en donner l'impression
parce que pour machiavel on n'est pas
tenu de dire la vérité au peuple
on n'est pas tenu d'être juste envers le
peuple pour machiavel
on est tenu de garder pouvoir selon
machiavel l'être humain réagit d'abord
aux apparences il ne réagit pas à la
réalité l'être humain ne réagit pas de
manière rationnelle
il réagit à l'affect il réagit aux
sentiments il réagit aux apparences
donc le bon gouvernant n'est pas celui
qui va donner au peuple ce qu'il veut le
bon gouvernant et celui qui va réussir à
faire croire au peuple qui lui donne ce
qu'il veut
le bon gouvernant cette année
illusionniste le mont gouvernance et
celui qui maîtrise l'art des apparences
parce que ce sont les apparences qui ont
un impact somme parce que nous réalisons
d'abord aux apparences pour alice ont
d'abord aux impressions la plupart de
nos opinions sont construites sur des
apparences on construction des faux
semblants sont construites sur des
illusions et quel est le matériau du
gouvernement sinon l'opinion
quel meilleur moyen de contrôler un
peuple que de s'appuyer sur ses opinions
l'opinion du peuple c'est la donnée
fondamentale à partir de laquelle les
gouvernants vont pouvoir organiser la
domination du peuple
et d'ailleurs ce n'est pas un hasard si
machiavel s'est beaucoup intéressé à la
psychologie humaine et notamment à ce
qu'on appelait autrefois les humeurs et
les humeurs sa désigner les fluides
corporels
si influencer nos émotions et notre
tempérament
et donc si l'être humain fonctionne à
l'humeur si l'être humain fonctionne au
aux émotions et aux sentiments
à ce moment là il n'a pas besoin de
donner au peuple ce qu'il veut il ya
simplement besoin de lui faire croire
qu'on y donne ce qu'il veut de lui faire
croire qu'on est juste de lui faire
croire qu'on veut son bien il n'y a pas
besoin d'agir
effectivement dans le sens de l'intérêt
du peuple il ya simplement besoin que le
peuple soit persuadé que le gouvernement
agit selon ses intérêts c'est tout ce
qui compte
le reste se serait delà de la vertu mal
placé et un gouvernant n'a pas le temps
de se laisser bercer de chimères
il n'a pas le temps il a pas le temps de
s'encombrer avec ce genre de chose il
n'a pas le temps de s'encombrer avec la
morale parce que son but c'était pas
d'idée le peuple vers le bien son but
c'est de le gouverner alors c'est là
qu'on en arrive aux deux principaux
leviers que machiavel va identifier pour
réussir à se faire obéir du peuple le
premier levier c'est celui de la
sympathie le deuxième levier c'est celui
de la crainte donc on retrouve là les
ressorts habituels du comportement
humain c'est-à-dire l'amour et la peur
donc la sympathie c'est à dire aimer le
peuple et en a trimé ou plus exactement
vous l'aurez compris lui donner
l'impression qu'on lève pour en être
aimé mais également être craints par le
peuple est d'ailleurs machiavel précise
bien que des deux leviers l'amour et la
peur c'est la peur qui est le plus
solide être craint c'est plus efficace 4
mm parce qu'il n'ya rien de plus
puissant en l'homme que la peur de la
mort face à la peur de la mort il n'y a
plus aucun amour qui tient donc pour
machiavel
nous ne sommes pas des héros nous ne
sommes pas aptes au sacrifice
ça ce sont des cas marginaux des cas
exceptionnels sur lesquels on ne peut
pas fonder une action politique c'est
pas possible de se baser sur des cas
aussi minoritaire pour construire les
fondations de la cité donc puisque les
êtres humains ont peur de la mort il
faut savoir jouer sur leurs peurs pour
pouvoir les conformer pour pouvoir les
rendre dociles et obéissants
parce que vous trouverez beaucoup de
personnes qui accepteront de faire
quelque chose par amour vous en voulez
encore plus qui accepteront de faire la
même chose par crainte donc là
j'insisterai simplement sur cette idée
que vous avez maintenant je pense bien
intégré qui est que la morale n'était
pas un problème pour machiavel
c'est pas un problème c'est pas la
mauvaise conscience qu'ils étouffent
qu'on soit bien clair il faut vraiment
intégré cette idée là parce que sinon on
va parler dans le vent comprendre que la
politique selon mme attias welz est
totalement indépendant de la morale
ça signifie que si dans une certaine
situation la morale est utile pour
gouverner le peuple
à ce moment là on fera le choix de la
morale mais si dans une autre situation
c'est l'immoralité qui peut servir à
gouverner les hommes on ira dans
l'immoralité
là pas de problème il n'y a pas de
jugement a priori sur la nature du bien
et la nature du mal chez machiavel il y
a un point de vue pragmatique une
approche rationnelle qui consiste à se
demander quelle est la stratégie la plus
efficace
quel est le moyen le plus efficace
d'augmenter notre emprise sur le peuple
c'est ça la seule question y en a pas
d'autre et c'est pour ça qu'on parle
d'un réalisme politique est un
pragmatisme politique parce qu'on a
totalement évacué la notion même de
transcendance il ya plus de
transcendance dans l'état de machiavel
la plus transcendant ce parce qu'il n'ya
plus d'échelle de valeur
il n'y a plus d'idées du bien donc s'il
n'ya pas bien il n'a pas de mal
et s'il n'ya ni bien ni mal il n'y a
aucun obstacle
il n'y a aucun empêchement à l'action du
gouvernement il n'y a aucune contrainte
si ce n'est celle de l'efficacité
si ce n'est celle du résultat qu'on
souhaite obtenir c'est ça le critère de
l'action politique chez machiavel c'est
l'efficacité
l'efficacité en termes de conservation
et de consolidation du pouvoir
donc il est faux de dire que la
philosophie de machiavel est un
immoralisme ce n'est pas un immoralisme
c'est un amoralisme c'est une doctrine
qui se passe de la morale c'est une
autre et qui évacue la question morale
et non pas une doctrine qui
chercheraient à s'opposer
systématiquement à la morale c'est très
différent
on a presque ici ce que j'appellerais un
proto utilitarisme un utilitarisme avant
l'heure un utilitarisme avant l'heure
parce que on évalue une action au juge
sa valeur non pas à partir des principes
qui la motive mais des résultats
qu'elles engendrent salle critères
d'évaluation moral chez les
utilitaristes c'est le résultat en
termes de bonheur produit bon avec
machiavel c'est pas la quantité de
bonheur qui compte c'est la quantité de
pouvoir tout simplement
donc on conseille pas aux gouvernements
de faire le mal pour faire le mal on
conseille aux gouvernants de faire le
mal quand ça peut avoir un résultat
positif sur la consolidation de son
pouvoir qu'il n'a pas de bien ou de mal
en soi n'y a pas de bien de mal avec une
majuscule
il y a des moyens pour atteindre un but
qui est conservation et consolidation du
pouvoir
alors là ça peut être le moment de vous
lire un petit extrait d'un texte de
machiavel un extrait qui va vous donner
une idée assez nette de la pensée de
machiavel sur justement cette absence de
distinction entre le bien et le mal
cette idée que le bien le mal ne sont
que des moyens pour atteindre un but un
prince bien avisés ne doit point
accomplir sa promesse lorsque cet
accomplissement lui seraient nuisibles
et que les raisons qui l'on déterminé à
promettre n'existe plus ne serait pas
bon sans doute si les hommes étaient
tous gens de bien mais comme ils sont
méchants qu'assurément et ne vous
tiendrez point leur parole
pourquoi devriez-vous tenir la vôtre ce
qui est absolument nécessaire
c'est de savoir bien déguisé cette
nature de renard est de posséder
parfaitement l'art de simuler et de
dissimuler on doit bien comprendre qu'il
n'est pas possible à un prince
d'observer dans sa conduite tout ce qui
fait que les hommes sont réputés gens de
bien et qu'il est souvent obligé pour
maintenir l'état d'agir contre
l'humanité contre la charité contre la
religion même il faut donc qu'ils aient
l'esprit assez flexibles pour se tourner
à toute chose selon que le vent et les
accidents de la fortune le commande
il faut comme je les dis autant qu'il le
peut il ne s'écarte pas de la voie du
bien mais qu au besoin ils sachent
entrer dans celle du mal voilà donc on a
un texte totalement explicite sur le
pragmatisme politique de machiavel sur
l'absence de référence à une entité
morale ou à une autorité divine celle
exposée absolument claire de
l'opportunisme morale dont le gouvernant
doit devenir un maître s'il veut
conserver son pouvoir
alors vont marquer le champ lexical qui
est assez intéressant machiavel dit que
le dirigeant doit se montrer
suffisamment flexibles flexible
signifiant ici qui doit savoir fermer
les yeux sur le mal fermé les yeux sur
ce que la morale réprouve
fermer les yeux sur le vice c'est assez
drôle de relever un un terme comme celui
ci qui se veut totalement neutre
justement parce que la démarche de
machiavel se veut moralement neutre se
veut axiologiquement neutre parce
qu'encore une fois on ne gouverne bien
les hommes que quand on comprend ce sont
les hommes
et d'ailleurs il le dit lui même la
plupart des hommes ne tiennent pas leurs
promesses donc pourquoi le gouvernement
devrait tenir ses promesses
voyez 7e cette conception de la nature
humaine qui va complètement conditionner
la doctrine politique de machiavel
complètement ce qui compte c'est le
résultat
le résultat en termes de conservation du
pouvoir c'est ce qui fait qu'on pourrait
s'intéresser pour conclure cette vidéo
sur cette question très simple est ce
que finalement en voulant disqualifié
toutes les valeurs morales toutes les
valeurs transcendantes
est-ce que machiavel n'a pas simplement
opéré un transfert de sacralité
est ce que le sacré n'est pas passée de
la morale à l'état de la morale à la
politique
est ce qu'au final cette raison d'état
n'a pas supplanté par anticipation la
raison morale de quant au xviiie siècle
et si c'est le cas ça pose une autre
question qui est de savoir est ce que la
raison d'état est compatible avec la
raison du peuple est ce que la raison du
pouvoir peut s'articuler à la raison
citoyenne
ça c'est une vraie question une vraie
question sur laquelle on aura tous une
opinion mais davantage dans cette
histoire c'est que en produisant ce
petit manuel à l'usagé gouvernants
machiavel a simultanément produit un
manuel de compréhension des gouvernants
un manuel à la disposition des citoyens
pour comprendre comment les gouvernantes
dirige peut-être que sans même le
vouloir machiavel a fait la même chose
que la boétie
lorsqu'il écrivait son traité sur la
servitude volontaire c'est à dire donner
les outils de compréhension et d'action
qui nous permettrait de nous émanciper
d'une certaine manière est-ce que
machiavel n'a pas offert aux citoyens le
cadeau de la prise de conscience de soi
est ce qu'il nous a pas offert le moyen
de comprendre ce que nous représentons
quand nos dirigeants
est ce que pour reprendre une idée
gallienne nos gouvernants ne tirait pas
leur pouvoir des gouvernés
est ce que les gouvernants existerait
encore sont les gouverner pour leur
obéir
c'est une question à laquelle je vous
laisserais bien entendu répondre pour
vous même j'espère en tout cas que cet
exposé nous aura intéressé on se
retrouve bientôt pour une prochaine
vidéo et d'ici là comme d'habitude
soyez sages
[Musique]
oh